the sentence three is coming this summer
what bands wait for this highly
anticipated threequel
they've kept themselves occupied how you
asked by obsessing over all the possible
hookups that may occur in the newest
villain kids movie here's a list of our
favorite potential descendants three
couples were shipping right now the one
at the end might surprise you all right
let's get wicked something happened to
me when I was on the aisle with uma the
connection mal and Ben let's start with
the most obvious one first true fans at
the first and second descendants movies
know that Ben and mal go back a long
time in the first movie now cast a love
spell on Ben but then found herself
falling for the young prince in spite of
herself at the end of the first
descendants movie now stood up to her
mother and said that she wanted to be
good she chose to turn away from her
evil roots and stay at auradon prep with
Ben and the other fairy tale at
descendants which was a big bummer for
Maleficent who turned into a lizard in
descendants - mal tried so hard to fit
in and be the perfect partner to Ben but
then she decided she couldn't take the
pressure of being good all the time so
she ran away to the Isle then Ben got
kidnapped by uma and her crew and mal
had to save him the movie ends with mal
and been singing and dancing happily
that is after mal turned into a dragon
and battled uma as her sea creature self
now learned that she could be herself
while still loving then who knows if Ben
and mal will end up together in
descendents 3 but fans are hoping they
do Evie and Doug who can forget the
sweet romance that blossom between Evie
and Doug and descendants - we all know
that Doug worked as Evie's assistant
while she was making the gowns and suits
for the cotillion fans shared a
collective sigh when Doug encouraged
Evie to buy her own castle so she never
had to wait for her prince and then
there was the moment when Doug held
Evie's hand and Evie put her hand on top
of his after that Doug totally flipped
out when Jay and Carlos told him that
Edie went camping to cover up her trip
back to the Isle to rescue Ben Doug was
pretty surprised when he heard that Evie
went camping he couldn't imagine Evie
who always wanted her own castle
sleeping on the ground
without a place to plug in her hair
dryer so we burst in and asked her if
she was seeing someone else she said
don't be dopey and gave him a little
kiss on the cheek dance thought it was
adorable that Doug didn't care about the
fall of auradon
or the fact that Ben had been kidnapped
all he cared about was Evie so will
these two stay together for descendant 3
we'll just have to wait and see Jay and
Lani Jay and Lani had quite a few sparks
flying between them in descendants - in
the movie Lani shows her skills as a
talented athlete who really wants to be
on the swords and shields team but Chad
charming says she can't be on the team
because it's all men but Lani doesn't
give up that easily after learning about
the fake one she blackmails Carlos and
Jade to convince them to take her to the
Isle to defeat Ouma because of her
amazing sword wielding talents Jay asks
her to come with him to practice and
makes her captain of the swords and
shields team this takes advantage of a
loophole in the rulebook which states
that a team must be comprised of a
captain and eight men Jay steps down as
captain so Lani can take his place
needless to say fans were shipping Jay
and Lani pretty hard they're really
perfect for each other but according to
the castle is for descendant three Lani
might not be making an appearance the
actress who plays her Diane Doan is
nowhere to be found on the list fans are
still holding out hope that she'll be
back for d3 so that Jay and Lani can be
reunited carlos and jane it's pretty
clear that carlos has a crush on jane
and descendants - he tries to ask her to
go to cotillion with him but jean is
frantic with planning the big event
carlos is shy and his rendered
speechless he tries to get up the
courage to ask her out but he chickens
out instead he asks her if she liked the
carrot cake from the night before she
replies that she had the pumpkin pie
Carlos tries again to ask gene to go to
the cotillion but Gina's so stressed out
from the planning that she jokes that
they should just give it all together
then she puts Carlos right in the center
of the friendzone when she tells him how
nice it is to have a friend like him
when he finally spits it out that he
wants to go together there's a bit of
confusion Jane still thinks they're
going as friends but Carlos persists and
tells her would you consider
maybe being more than friends jeana's
thrilled and tells Carlos how nice and
cute he is then they go together to
cotillion and dance happily ever after
so will they still be together in d3 it
seems very likely Audrey and Chad
although Audrey was a no-show in
descendants - except for the brief bone
conversation with Chad there's a lot of
speculation about her role in d3 Disney
released some onset photos of Audrey and
costume next to Chad and let's just say
Audrey looks quite different than she
did in the first movie it appears that
Audrey has traded in her sweet pink
dress for some edgier threads and she
appears to be holding Maleficent staff
in the picture Audrey who now has pink
hair is throwing her head back and
cackling while Chad charming stands
there looking very scared the last we
heard of Audrey was when she called Chad
to tell him that her car broke down in
the Sherwood Forest maybe something
happened to her in that forest and she
turned evil before Chad got there so
will Chad follow her to the dark side or
will he be too scared to keep the
relationship going
we know that Audrey had her heart set on
Ben in the first movie she only dated
Chad to try and make Ben Jealous
if she has turned evil who's to say she
won't has to spell on Ben and take him
away from mal uma and Harry if they were
a couple their ship name would be Huma
it makes a lot of sense for Harry and
uma to be together they both have evil
parents who have come from the sea and
they're both undoubtedly wicked it's
only natural that fans would be
obsessing over these two as a couple one
tumblr page called Puma Haven has laid
out a pretty solid theory about uma and
Harry's relationship it starts with some
casual flirting in the book rise of the
Isle of the loss but their chemistry
gets pretty intense in descendants -
during Yuma's what's my name number
during the song uma winks at Harry more
than once
Harry vows before her removes his hat
and slowly says her name it looks like
he's about to propose to her then
uma hooks her finger around Harry's hook
in a very flirtatious way then there's a
moment when uma runs her fingers through
Harry's hair and he looks like he's
falling in love with her right then
there it's pretty clear that fans expect
major sparks to fly between harry and
uma in descendants three Carlos and J
there's a lot of fan art and fan fiction
about Carlos and J hooking up this
tumblr fan drew a pretty convincing
picture of the two of them together and
there's another fan art with the two of
them kissing dance must have been
inspired by the chemistry of these two
on screen even if they are just buddies
in the films
remember that time Carlos jumped into
Jays arms it was pretty sweet another
fan wrote a fantasy tale saying that Jay
and Carlos are so close their
girlfriends joke that there are each
other's boyfriends
the boys joke too and refer to each
other as boyfriends even though they
have girlfriends there's clearly a fan
obsession with these two becoming more
than just friends well it's unlikely
that Jay and Carlos will get together in
d3 fans think it's fun to imagine a
romance between these two harry and gil
many fans have speculated on what it
would be like if harry and gil took time
off from pirating to hook up one fan
said they think harry and Gil are
totally crushing and added that mouth is
the biggest beard in aisle history there
was that one picture floating around the
internet of harry and gil kissing many
fans thought it was a deleted scene from
descendants - there's still some
speculation among fans about whether or
not Harry and Gil we're supposed to kiss
in that scene according to Seventeen
magazine Harry and Gil do actually kiss
in the novelization of descendants - but
for some reason the kiss did not make it
into the film so maybe if harry and uma
don't end up together
sparks will fly between these two
scallywags and considering the fact that
Carlos didn't find a love interest until
his second film maybe the same will be
true for Harry and kill even wicked
pirates deserve love so who will win
Harry over well uma become captain of
his heart or will kill charm him into
his strong muscular arms fans will just
have to wait until descendant 3 comes
out this summer to find out maleficent
in hades the castle is for descendants
three is out and it looks like
Maleficent played by Kristin Chenoweth
is absent from this list fans are
assuming this means she won't be making
an appearance in the upcoming threequel
but from what we can gather from the d3
teaser mouse dad is deaf
we going to be involved many have
speculated that Hades played by Cheyenne
Jackson will be Mouse father but Disney
has been keeping it pretty under wraps
still if Hades is mouths dad that means
that he and Maleficent were once a
couple so what would happen if they
remembered why they got together in the
first place and rekindled their
relationship one thing is for sure
Maleficent would have to figure out how
to change herself back from her lizard
form and it looks like Hades is just
this blue glowing light in the forest in
the teaser the odds are definitely
stacked against these two as far as
reuniting but maybe they will see how
happy mal is with Ben and decide they
want to find love again
- stranger things have happened remember
the talking dog from d2 anything is
possible
Audrey and uma this one may seem a bit
far-fetched but hear us out from the
look of Audrey's new outfit her evil
cackle and the fear in Chad's eyes and
the fact she's holding Maleficent
scepter it's clear she's becoming a
villain
Audrey is pretty peeved at mal for
stealing her boyfriend Ben Huma may
decide to capitalize on that jealousy
and anger it's possible that Huma Lord
Audrey into the forest and put a spell
on her you know the way she did to dizzy
in The Descendants short story under the
sea so under umas control audrey is
capable of anything
after audrey has a taste of Yuma's
powers she may decide she wants to be
with her instead of chasing boys then
Audrey can help uma and the other
villain kids from the Isle infiltrate
auradon Audrey may know a way for them
to sneak into auradon undetected and
Audrey can get back at now for stealing
her boyfriend and for wind mouths mom
put Audrey's mom in a coma it's a
stretch but fans have come up with a lot
of unlikely matches for descendents
three which one was your favorite is
there a couple we miss if so let us know
in the comments below and those were the
descendants three couples that we ship
be sure to subscribe to the things to
get all our latest videos on d3 and
click the thumbs up button if you like
this video see you next time
[Music]